[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans ce premier
six ans par les spores de l'année à 2019
toute l'équipe de t'aimer 78 se joint à
moi pour vous souhaiter une très belle
année
et pour que cette année débute
parfaitement nous vous avons concocté un
talk sportif de haute volée cinq
chroniqueurs vont m'accompagner
aujourd'hui dans cette émission
présentation en musique on commence à ma
droite sa résolution en 2019 il veut
aller toujours plus vite sur son vélo
pour remporter des médailles
et si possible en or le capitaine yann
dujarrier du club de vélizy 78 est
encore avec nous aujourd'hui en 2019
en 2010 neuf tours au talent et brian
très très bien je sors de l'entraînement
résolution 8 ou pas à l'entraînement non
je veux toujours plus de compétition en
compétition donc l'autre alors comment
vous traîner un petit peu chez les
efforts mais ils n'arrivent pas à
reproduire ce que à fin mai dans le même
état que plus que je pourrai faire mon
complète moi c'est c'est bizarre on vous
en verrez les vidéos en tous cas en
passe de l'autre côté un musique sa
résolution 2019 réaliser des figures
jamais vu dans son sport de prédilection
la pole dance une passion quatre
pratiques à versailles notre
ambassadrice de charme
hélène de la grange est encore avec nous
aujourd'hui je suis ravi
alors les figures jamais vu je pense qu
il doit y en avoir il ya des centaines
de figurants sur que non que oui après
de là à avoir la prétention de dire
qu'on invente quelque chose vous avez
écrit star oui on passe de l'autre côté
musique sa résolution 2019
regardez un peu moins de rugby à la
télévision ça va être difficile avec le
tournoi des six nations qui va commencer
notre gladiateurs pierre chevalier du
rugby-club de versailles ou fait une
nouvelle fois bonheur de venir former
bonheur à tous comment aller mais super
bien gravi de recommencer cette année
par cette saison mais cette année avec
vous tous et toutes vous allez pouvoir
tenir leurs résolutions difficile
il ya un beau programme en plus cette
année avec une année de coupe du monde
ça va être difficile
on repasse de l'autre côté un musique sa
résolution 2019 ne rien changer il a
toujours dans son sac des dizaines de
blagues et on va passer un très bon
moment avec lui aujourd'hui j'en suis
sûr la légende le mythe coach genlis
l'ancien entraîneur de plaisir est avec
nous il rejoint la bande
bonne soirée télé une bonne année bonne
année à tous à tout on voit toutes et à
tous vous êtes un serveur premier non
dénommée rue de 2019 heureux d'être ici
doivent y est on termine à ma droite
musique sa résolution 2019 mais plutôt
son défi jouer dans le prochain euro en
référence à son surnom dans cette
émission notre spécialiste équitation le
zorro yves binois raul côté de trait est
avec nous pendant une heure raul7 de
retour parmi les ouvrants michael ray
soit une grande année sportive à à tous
ceux qui nous regardent et aux yvelinois
et aux yvelinois en priorité alors avant
de passer au programme de l'émission
j'aimerais qu'on revienne rapidement sur
une actualité qui nous a fait beaucoup
rire pendant les fêtes de noël trois
mois après avoir mené l'europe à la
victoire à la ryder cup 2018 face aux
états unis au golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines le capitaine
européen thomas bjorn a honoré son pari
en se faisant tatouer la coupe et le
score de la 42e édition sur le
postérieur regarder
les bébés
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pierre chevalier vous avez fait la même
chose après la ryder cup pour tout dire
pour te dire honnêtement j'ai une
confrérie de deux petits camarades avec
qui nous joue au golf chaque année il ya
une veste verte a remporté pour le
gagnant et cuillère de bois apprend et
depuis quelques années le le risque
encouru par celui qui paume c'est
d'avoir à peu près la même le même
traitement
je pense que ça va arriver un jour vous
en parle cette même zone pour l'instant
je n'ai pas perdu non non j'en ai
souvent pensé quand tu as i am et
fantastic
c'est énorme moi j'adore ce genre de
d'humour vous et des tatouages comme
celui là encore n'a jamais aimé voir je
peux pas dire à la télévision parce que
j'ai encore faire taxer non non hélène
non mais moi je n'en pensais pas moi je
trouve ça mignon puis oui c'est de
l'humour en même temps voilà ils
essaient il est passionné par son sport
donc et puis c'est pas un truc énorme
non plus donc ça reste
moi ça me fait bien rire il a bien
raison de lacunes ans est la zone qui
vous a dérangé ça m'a pas dérangé mais
je me suis dit quand même pour un
premier tatouage chez
voilà on est en toute discrétion c'est
très bien mais je pense que c'est pas la
zone la plus sensible du corps il ya ça
fait entre un petit peu plus dans la
légende en vraiment de de la ryder cup
je pense que c'est un beau coup de
publicité c'est génial d'avoir été
jusqu'au bout du jusqu'au bout du truc
en effet un tatouage sur sur la fesse il
va pas être dérangé au quotidien
maintenant je pense que ça risque de
faire parler
peut-être qu'il aura par les supporters
qui peuvent lui demander de deux si
j'allais dire que peut-être avoir un
souci avec la ceinture qu'il va falloir
lever c'est souvent pour montrer pour
beaucoup ce poster
mais voilà ce sera toujours dans un bon
sens et humoristique c'est parfait
raul qu'est ce qu'ils ont pensé à moi à
l'origine je sape a trop été de mon
ghoul les tatouages et autres piercing
etc
mais quand cela représente un symbole
assez profond finalement je les
possibles
je voulais c'était pas pour blaguer en
plus les négociales c'est bon il ya un
rapport par rapport à l'exploit ou bon
voilà on coup de pub sur l'amp pour
l'ambiance du golf ça détend un petit
peu le côté un petit peu guindée ça
détend le string on va dire plus vu la
zone on peut garder du golfe et c'est
très bien c'est un joli coup de pub qui
a fait le tour sur twitter notamment et
ça reste esprit raidard gamin c'est
l'esprit ryder cup les arcades voilà
on est là pour faire la fête et pour
battre les américains alors nous allons
maintenant passer au programme de
l'émission aujourd'hui nous allons
parler de handball avec la venue de la
joueuse slovène hanina jerry cheech à
montigny le bretonneux nous ferons
également un coup de projecteur sur la
course cycliste paris nice qui passera
par les yvelines au mois de mars mais
avant de développer ces thèmes on va
parler de football américain on commence
donc par du football américain c'était
la reprise pour les templiers
d'elancourt ils ont dû s'employer ce
samedi 12 janvier pour remporter leur
première victoire de la saison dans le
championnat de deuxième division les
footballeurs saint quentinois ont réussi
à battre les pionniers de touraine à
domicile dans le money time dans les
toutes dernières minutes score final 14
à 13 on écoute les réactions au micro de
tv 78 la victoire est toujours mérité on
sait on s'est battu pour pour aller la
chercher
on était mené tout le match qu'on est
parti le chercher sur le dernier drive
et au final on a juste marque un peu
plus que les autres ce qu'il fallait
faire victoire méritée puisque 60
victoires ce ce bon à prendre
après la manière n'est pas forcément là
mais il ya une réaction par rapport à
cette victoire
14 13 a larache voilà je suis une
victoire qui peut être encourageante
pour la suite
bien sûr c'est bien de gagner quand
c'est dans la difficulté il vaut mieux
finir sur une note positive quand quand
le match a été difficile parce que ça
permet justement de d'évacuer plus
facilement la frustration plutôt que de
perm qu'il a peut vraiment mettre un
coup au moral alors après on est sur le
début de la saison on ne faut pas de
voler mais voilà premier mari ne faut
pas vous pas s'alarmer mais c'est bien
de commencer sur une sur une note
positive
hélène victoire c'est une victoire peu
importe la manière
oui c'est cette victoire avec la manière
c'est mieux et puis ça met dans une
bonne dynamique ça encourage et ils vont
avoir l'impression que ces partis après
faut pas non plus se reposer sur les
lauriers s'est jamais qu'un point donc
c'est pas non plus une énergie temps
mais bon c'est un bon début et début de
saison qui encourage quan genre 14-13 au
forceps ça vous va ben je t'ai dit c'est
un début de saison premier match de la
saison sont peut-être encore en plein
réglages cette fusion modifier certaines
choses certaines
certes elle est souvent la semaine de
jeu et et que c'est pas encore tout à
fait au point mais la victoire est là
donc il n'ya pas il n'y a pas du tout le
feu en tout cas que les plans villiers
wii ou la rue que du positif
côté positif en tout cas les templiers
se sont faits a très peur eux qui
espéraient passer une soirée tranquille
à la mi temps ils étaient menés 6 à 0
sur leur terrain face à ces pionniers de
touraine et pourtant les templiers avait
annoncé quelques jours plus tôt leurs
pronostics sur ce plateau de tv 78 il
était plutôt confiant on les écoute un
petit pronostique une victoire des
tentes et yes we can moi je dirais une
victoire des templiers avec 20 points
d'écart on va parler car alexander 50
points d'écart 50 points d'écart les
héros pour les lignes et de touraine
si je m'occupe de la défense et devrait
y avoir zéro pour les je ne sais plus
comment il s'appelle
une réaction par rapport à l'interview
pierre chevalier dans un contexte quand
même qu'ils pondent peut-être un manque
d'humilité avant de démarrer cette
saison
donc ils ont été pris à leur propre jeu
avec avec un match assez difficile a dû
piquer au vif les pionniers de touraine
une région chère à chère à mon coeur et
vous vous rappeliez en préparation de
cette émission qu a priori cette vidéo
avait enfin cette vidéo est l'émission
avait dû tourner sur les réseaux sociaux
je pense qu'ils ont ils en ont profité
pour bien aiguisé leur leur stratégie et
puis pour poser des problèmes aux
templiers d'elancourt bleus quel est
votre avis du coup sûr sur cette
interview vous pensez que ça a motivé
les pionniers d'un coin salle moi c'est
aussi ce que je cherche un petit peu
dans l'enseignement chez mais chez mes
jeunes sportifs l'humilité est
importante mais parfois les excès de
confiance la sueur motivation le fait de
croire en soi avec excès est important
aussi
là en l'occurrence il semblerait que il
ya un état d'esprit de sous-estimer
l'adversaire qui c'est pour ça que le
score est inattendu et qu'ils ont eu
chaud donc je crois que cette
combativité là il faut pas le faire
mourir mais effectivement retourner dans
quelque chose de plus humbles et de plus
en plein avec la réalité la question sur
ce thème justement à l'excès de
confiance se peut-il perturber la saison
des templiers
vous votez oui oui oui
non il faut pas c'est peut-être la
raquette ah non voilà c'est ça vous avez
de raquette alors qu'un petit duel entre
jean et pierre jean pierre jean pierre
genre vous commencez donc pour vous oui
ça peut les perturber et ça peut les
perturber
dans la mesure où là il faudrait qui
redescend un petit peu sur terre
j'espère que le match leur a fait du
bien elle aura servi de leçon
parce que bon on a tous parlé autour la
l'humilité c'est très important dans le
milieu sportif
ça doit être peut-être les coûts zen de
l'entraîneur de chevreuse là qui avait
fait ses preuves du nez l'an mil et mini
militer face à face au ska il
en fait ce qu'on aime regarder sur le
plateau il faut faire attention parce
que ben un match n'est jamais gagné
d'avancé
et puis surtout faut respecter
l'adversaire donc je pense que j'espère
pour eux que ce match-là laura leur a
appris beaucoup de choses et je pense
que la prochaine fois qu'il soit
interviewé sur sur un match ils
parleront trouve en quoi parce que rien
n'est défini à l'avancé
et effectivement si nan pas et n'allons
pas tenez les enseignements ça risque de
leur porte tort sur la fed sur le
déroulement de leur saison après je
pense que c'est juste un excès de kool
shen c'est que ces passagers
pierre je pense que ça ne peut pas
perturber leur région leur saison passée
pour deux raisons la première c'est
qu'ils ont gagné et la deuxième c'est on
voyait sur votre sur le journal des
sports de lundi sur le plateau que cet
effet copieusement bouger par leur part
leurs différents entraîneurs justement
être écoutés on valide en testant le
coach qui les a leur a donné une petite
soufflante à la fin ouais on écoute le
mental les gars psychologiquement on
doit être au-dessus
on vient de la d1 vous connaissez
l'historique du club tôt
faut il fait tout ça la ne peut pas se
mettre au niveau de nos adversaires
c'est pas possible
voilà la soufflante et c'est donc un
avertissement sans frais il gagne nos
matches sur le film ils gagnent ils se
sont bougés
donc ils vont vite dégonfler le melon
ou justement ne plus faire d'excès
d'excès de zèle ou d'excès de sur
motivation comme disait raul faire
preuve d'humilité et comme là où je
rejoins jean c'est respecter
l'adversaire respecter la logique
sportive prendre là encore on le dit
souvent les matches les uns après les
autres et je pense qu'au contraire ça
peut ça peut jouer comme un révélateur
et un avertissement sans frais qui va
les remettre un petit peu dans laxe bien
dujarrier qui vous a convaincu jean
pierre pierre je me suis fait reste
vierge
vous savez j'avais mis vert mais c'est
vrai que j'aurais j'aurais de divers en
dix ans la même chose que pierre a dit
quoi donc
donc voilà l'annoncé pour moi pour moi
c'est ça c'est un avertissement sans
frais en conséquence et mais par contre
voilà maintenant faut faut être humble
mais par contre enfin il faut respecter
l'adversaire mais moi j'ai souvent une
même type de comportement alors avec une
enfin voila c'est à dire que j'ai besoin
aussi de charrier mes adversaires de
rentrer dans ce dans ce combat
écologique away combat psychologique
alors on va surtout dans un sport comme
je suis fou sur la mairie copains parce
que j'ai toujours était copain qui avait
des adversaires mais c'est vrai que j'ai
besoin de ça aussi ii pour galvaniser
pour me motiver à l'entraînement dispose
d'un agrément sable
on voit beaucoup dans les sports de
combat aussi ce besoin de se transcender
de sortir fondamentalement supérieur
hélène qu'est-ce que vous en pensez ouf
je rejoins ce qu'ils disent par contre
je pense qu'on peut se sentir supérieur
et se galvaniser et sans pour autant
elle est vraiment dans le danger kraz
mon adversaire et c'était on peut aller
à la confrontation et et narguer un peu
ce qu'il faut peut-être mais de là à
être que le ascendant là on va dire dans
le vestiaire plutôt que le dire dans les
médias
déjà je pense que je pense que ça se
passe déjà entre sportifs sur un terrain
de boxe fin sur un ring de boxe ou ou
comme toi jan quand tu vas courir et que
tu es face à d'autres personnes ou bien
même avec les membres de ton équipe et
que c'est une espèce un peu de course
etc
même si ça se descend un peu ça reste un
peu le je pense à comportement normal
après de là à l'affiché de façon
prétentieuse et que l'adversaire en face
puisse pas rétorqué me dire quoi que ce
soit cette simulation auto gratuite mais
c'est vrai que pouvoir dire ce que l'on
pense directement à l'adversaire et qui
puisse répondre derrière moi je suis là
moi c'est plus à nos coéquipiers souvent
quand je faisais le départ de la vitesse
par équipes janvier fait attention à la
fin du premier tour que je vous dis pas
à rattraper
et donc c'était pour charrier les
copains mais c'est vrai que les besoins
de sade des pionniers de touraine vont
apporter la meilleure réponse à votre
avis excellent temps a bien sûr bien sûr
ça n'est ce pas la meilleure réponse sur
le terrain je pense qu'ils ont fait le
maximum de ce qu'ils pouvaient faire et
ça les a certainement galvanisé pour
aller chercher ce qu'ils ont ce qu'ils
ont mis derrière chercheurs après tout
la question leur poser
lundi aussi c'était aux gens d'aller
sport ou avant c'est une question piège
un pronostic
quand on est effectivement seul sur un
plateau médias et qu'on est con on
demande un brin pronostics
la confiance en soi et la motivation
doit nous dire qu'on doit gagner par
contre de dire qu'elle est de 50 e 20
points d'écart sans en prendre à en
défense c'est là que le bât blesse âge
genre la petite soufflante qu'est ce que
vous en avez pensé
c'est une fête sans trembler les murs à
chaque fois c'est ça chaque week-end
non c'était des comores c'était une
bonne soufflante oui je pense qu'il ya
mis le doigt là où il fallait
et en plus il leur dit on vous descendez
de dieu donc et il faut pas se mettre au
niveau
c'est ce qu'il ya de plus dur d'aller
dans les sports collectifs notamment
comme comme le football américain où
c'est très difficile je dois de garder
son niveau de jeu et d'élever tous les
images où toutes les compétitions son
niveau de jeu au dessus de l'adversaire
donc ça va être mon avis un gros
challenge qui vont ils vont avoir ce
suffisant pour pour pour les futurs
matches qu après le football américain
le rugby avec le championnat honneur
rien n'arrête versailles les hommes de
la cité royale ont remporté une 10e
victoire consécutive ce dimanche 13
janvier leur victime du jour monter son
deuxième du classement les versets ils
ont emporté 16 à 5 mais cette fois ci
sans le panache on écoute les réactions
à la fin du match je dirais que c'était
très haché donc ya pas eu
c'était dur mais c'était une équipe en
face qui est assez accrocheuse donc
eu du mal à mettre notre jeu en place
après on n'a pas non plus été trop mis
en difficulté en défense donc
voilà faut satisfaire de cette victoire
et de les éloigner du bonus défensif
avec cette victoire les versets et
compte douze unités d'avancé sur leur
dauphin montesson après dix journées
disputées la question sur ce thème
versailles est il déjà en fédérale 3 oui
pour jean non oui hélène hélène est
partagée pour vous visitiez raul j'ai
pas vu gémir en rouge également
on fait un petit duel entre eux allaient
edel et william n'ont pas d'avis
bon ils ont alors deux jours je suis ça
c'est encore à vous cinq ans à moi à
l'aise les câbles face à ian s qui sont
déjà en fédérale 3 est-ce qu'ils sont
déjà fait le trou pour les avoir dans la
poule pour les amendes à la boule je dis
oui puisqu'il reste celui huit matches
vous êtes chez les gif sur yvette
voilà crif sur yvette on y joue d'image
sont d'ailleurs versailles on les reçoit
du match donc pierre à faire un
pronostic après il faut un pronostic
on va la mettre ces quatre points et il
me trompe pas au point qu'on pourra
revenir sérieusement oui pour moi ils
sont déjà en fédérale 3 parce que leur
principal concurrent s'étaient montés
sans
il les a joués deux fois elles ont gagné
les deux matches que ce soit chez eux ou
device à la maison douze points d'avancé
reste vie rencontre c'est
mathématiquement on va dire que non ils
ont pas mais ça voudrait dire c'est à
dire que montesson devrait devrait
gagner sur les huit dernières rencontres
devraient gagner trois matches de plus
que versailles donc il faudrait que
versailles déjà en berne à perdre au
moins trois donc c'est frais c'est
quasiment c'est quasiment faisable ils
feront peut-être un ou deux faux pas
peut être un faux pas dimanche à
gif-sur-yvette par exemple mais mais
s'ils ont pour moi ils sont déjà en
fédérale 3
il faut après pierre a dit non mais
c'est la fausse modestie on parlait
juste avant des tabliers où il était
trop trop souvent passé un match en
trombe à ses meubles mais là ça
s'appelle la fausse modestie sans gêne
moi j'avais dit comme jean donc j'espère
aussi parce que maintenant temps que le
dernier match où tant que
mathématiquement ce n'est pas fait en
effet il peut y avoir il peut y avoir
soucis mais aujourd'hui avec l'avant ce
qu'ils ont ils ont démontré sur beaucoup
des matches qu'il était au dessus de au
dessus de la mêlée des clubs des clubs
adverses des clubs de leur poule donc
voilà il n'ya pas deux il n'y a pas de
nya pas ce qu'il y'a pas de suspense et
et tant mieux pour eux je pense qu'ils
vont pouvoir jouer relâché jusqu'à la
fin de la saison et ça va permettre
aussi peut-être de faire un peu de sang
neuf heures préfère préparer la saison
prochaine
il n'y a pas une histoire de
vous n'êtes pas une histoire de poules
match en fin de saison phase finale
voilà on veut préparer les phases
finales sereinement et ça et ça c'est
important d'avoir d'avoir fait ce qu'ils
ont ce qu'ils ont mis en place depuis
enfin d'avoir réussi à enchaîner toutes
ces victoires depuis la saison raoult
penser qu'ils peuvent se déconcentrer
moi j'ai franchement qu'est le mal a dit
que j'étais un geek du web et je crois
que c'est le sport collectif qui offre
le plus de surprise parce que du fait
que ce soit un sport de gros contact
physiquement je trouve que l'ascendant
physique peut renverser complètement un
match et je trouve qu'il est il est même
plus dangereux dans dans le rugby plutôt
que dans le foot de se projeter que al
avance sur sur les performances donc
voilà je tente la messe n'est pas dite
surtout dans le rugby je m'amuserais pas
un vrai mais fait pau et en plus je
crois simplement participe aux phases
finales ils ont même pas besoin de
leaders de la finir premier j'avoue j'ai
pas le choix que de répondre que répond
non il faut une fausse modestie
c'est vrai que ça se présente bien c'est
la premier dont on avait un projet et
sur versailles à trois ans pour remonter
en fédérale 3 on était descendu en 2016
on n'a jamais été aussi proche de la de
la montée qu'il est de finir premier de
sa poule
ça c'est la première chance c'est pour
finir premier de la poule où après aller
plus loin possible en phase finale mais
ça c'est beaucoup plus incertain donc la
certitude c'est terminé premier de la
poule à la fin de la saison régulière
hélas hélas c'est dans ces cas là la
montée est assurée ont parlé d'humilité
tout à l'heure
réponse précise à l'ats précise à la
question est ce que est ce que
versailles est déjà mathématiquement
fédérale 3
réponse est non il reste huit matches à
jouer après il est sûr que on sait on a
mis le maximum de chances de notre côté
10 matches 10 victoires et six bonus
offensif
dans une poule dans une poule d'île de
france ce qui est généralement en
ile-de-france on jeudi généralement un
bon rugby un bon niveau
donc il peut y avoir des faux pas il
peut y avoir non pas des impasses il y
aura pas d'impasse de notre de notre
côté par ses parents qui connaissait
bien des joueurs ou pour penser qu'ils
peuvent s'écrouler mentalement ou non
parce que l'appétit d'un soi disant que
c'est fait on l'a payé de l'appétit
vient en mangeant c'est à dire que là là
pour le coup on n'a pas non plus un
groupe on a un groupe en première d'une
trentaine de joueurs ça va permettre
comme des lianes de faire de faire
tourner un petit peu et donner à place à
nos jeunes juniors notamment qui sont
montés cette année de pouvoir jouer en
premier en réserve et de pouvoir
s'aguerrir un petit peu au niveau au
niveau régional avant de avant d'espérer
arriver au niveau fédéral mais non je
pense pas que je pense pas qu'ils
lâchent
c'est vraiment une un objectif un
objectif de terminer le mieux possible
si on peut terminer invaincus on le on
le fera évidemment à fond la caisse
chaque dimanche on joue on joue les
matches pour les gagner même même en se
déplaçant chez les redoutables des
adversaires comme comme jfe dimanche
prochain
donc ouais on prend on prend comme ça
vient on est bien parti mais personne ne
lâche et tout le monde reste concentré
et notamment pour aller jusqu'aux phases
finales et faire un maximum de chemin en
phase finale on va voir en tout cas si
le coach de l'équipe est d'accord avec
vous on écoute tout de suite de quoi des
autopsies sont claires c'est à dire que
nous on veut rien lâcher
on va essayer de gagner tous nos matches
comme on fait tous les tous les
week-ends le but va être aussi docile
intégré pas mal de joueurs comme on l'a
fait avec des rotations pour tout le
monde puisse goûter la belle aventure
est bien évidemment essayer d'aller le
plus haut possible après il a l'air
d'accord avec vous ravir on avait coaché
avant les matériaux méjean les gens il
faut commencer à préparer la saison
prochaine
oui peuvent commencer à préparer la
saison prochaine tout à fait tout à fait
dès janvier moi je oui oui oui parce que
il ya un tel écart entre entre ce groupe
pierre le disent et ils ont trente
joueurs à disposition pour le groupe
première il faut savoir qu agir par
exemple moi j'ai trente deux joueurs des
dispositions pour les deux équipes
amour et j'exagère mais c'est ça le
talent à clichy dimanche on était trente
deux donc demander des jours à pierre
voilà donc non mais c'est pour ça que
j'ai dit sur le niveau l'écart est
tellement important entre le groupe de
versailles et les autres groupes que oui
peuvent préparer la saison
la saison prochaine d'ores et déjà
pourquoi qu'ils y arrivent à monter pour
une épidémie la fraîcheur mise à part
une épidémie joue pas comme il pourrait
pas monter maintenant après ce qui
risque de faire un incorporant des des
nouveaux joueurs et des jeunes etc
d'affaiblir leur équipe et d'être
accroché par rapport à part certaines
équipes et troquer un petit peu le reste
du championnat des équipes qui ceux qui
se battent soit pour se maintenir
yvonne heures soit pour une
qualification et c'est ça risque
peut-être de trop mme kane qui peut le
char gras parce que c'est une équipe qui
logiquement devrait tout gagner jusqu'à
la fin de la saison régulière
ce sera le mot de la fin sur ce thème on
range maintenant orange maintenant les
ballons ovales on va parler cyclisme
dans notre focus du jour un mariage qui
dure depuis dix ans le paris-nice
partira une nouvelle fois depuis les
yvelines après chatou l'année dernière
saint jean les a été retenue comme ville
départ de cette 77e édition
les coureurs partiront le dimanche 10
mars du parc du château pour une grande
boucle de 130 8 5 km à travers les
yvelines en passant notamment par
touahri montfort l'amaury ou poissy les
réactions pourquoi saint germain parce
que saint germain c'est prestigieux
c'est saint germain c'est le château
parce que saint germain il ya des
perspectives formidables aussi pour la
transmission de la télé et parce qu'on
avait été super bien accueilli en 2013
dans un précédent départ de paris nice
nous avons énormément d'équipements
sportifs à saint germain en laye a pas
que le paris saint-germain il ya
énormément de pratique sportive et donc
c'est important effectivement de montrer
que c'est une étape qui populaire le
vélo c'est très populaire et on a en
plus nous à saint germain en laye une
politique autour des mobilités douces et
du vélo qui est forte
le lundi 11 mars à 12h35 précise le
peloton s'élancera des bréviaires pour
une étape de 163 5 km la petite commune
de 1300 habitants située dans le sud des
yvelines deviendra la 17e communes du
département à accueillir l'épreuve
l'érection
c'est un événement historique à la fois
pour les bréviaires et pour moi
personnellement atteint beaucoup de
monde je pense que on va voir toutes les
écoles voisines qui va en venir
participer avec des départs en vélo donc
tout le loisir toutes les communes
voisines
il ya saint germain
cité royale célèbre son château et puis
il ya de l'autre côté les bréviaires la
plus petite commune de paris nice 2010
hop on en est ravi les compétitions
cyclistes c'est ça sont des grandes
villes des villes moyennes et des
petites communes alors on ne va pas se
mentir généralement les organisateurs
sélectionne une grosse ville historique
du département comme ville départ comme
saint jean monnet par exemple puis une
petite commune du sud pour la deuxième
étape l'année dernière c'était alors son
ville par exemple en somme il vous en
souvenez alors la question son monument
alors la question sur ce thème est ce
que le paris nice a fait le tour dans
les yvelines
après dix ans non non non il faut
continuer pour genre vous avez pris
votre petite raquette en premier oui
c'était juste pour la lever c'est comme
ça alors ça c'est pas ça très bien c'est
puis c'est une des grandes courses
cyclistes que qu'on a en france donc les
yvelines et c'est un département de deux
vélos
il n'aime pas quand driss vélo mais il y
a tellement d'autres endroits qui sont
qui sont adaptés pour ce départ de
paris-nice que non la part fait le tour
on en est loin de faire le tour en dix
années
continuons continuons à accueillir cette
compétition sur le département des
yvelines
hélène ça fait quand même dix ans il
faut continuer oui après tout façon
département est quand même étendu les
itinéraires pour être choisi vraiment
chaque année différemment il ya plein de
petites villes il ya plein d'endroits
qui ou le cyclisme va pas forcément donc
je pense qu'on peut quand même pas mal
se renouveler après il ya forcément un
moment donné on aura fait vraiment
toutes les grosses villes et on aura un
petit peu tout retourné dans tous les
sens mais je pense que là on peut encore
rester quelques quelques années ou
qu'ils soient spécialistes cyclisme nous
vélo sur les deux principaux c'est un
principe qui dira que si vous prenez
votre vélo tous les dimanches pourrait
pour aller faire votre entraînement de
même pour les rôles et 55 cents kilos
mais vous faites du vélo alors que si
vous accrochez un dossard le dimanche
quand tout est une compétition fait du
cyclisme
voilà un petit peu ma manu ans donc donc
elles envoient du jeu là on est sur le
cyclisme ben moi je suis super fan c'est
vrai que de voir des bd beau départ des
beaux départs sur sur les yvelines c'est
très bien l'année dernière on a eu quand
même un super finish un beau hasard si
avec arnaud démare qui remporte la
dernière étape il ya deux ans à bonnart
6 t2
ouais donc voila mais c'est pas grave
donc ça n'empêche que fondation nahd
on a dit ça passe vite et on a des
belles on a des belles arrivées ans elle
est belle étape
je me souviens de coignières moi j'ai
hâte qu'il revienne karine sur saint
quentin en yvelines on a on a
possibilité de faire autre chose et de
faire ailleurs on et ça fait très
longtemps aussi qu'on les a pas vus
annonce a eu le le contre la montre dans
le dans les sept tournant il n'y a pas
si si l'on ne sait pas si longtemps que
ça alors je serai pas de données d'année
puisque est donc maintenant il ya plein
de choses à faire dans les yvelines il
ya plein de c'est un vrai terrain de jeu
pour les pour les cyclistes donc dongo
il faut il faut il faut que ça continue
et je pense que fin voilà c'est vrai qu'
on est très proche de paris paris nice
ça doit partir de là de la région
parisienne donc continuer comme ça avant
la course a retrouvé une partie du parc
plus heavy luis maintenant oui mais à
regarder paris n'avait pas retrouvé par
de compiègne donc
ça ça perd un peu donc non non c'est
très bien que ça reste que ça reste chez
nous j'espère que ça va rester très
longtemps on reçoit quand même un petit
peu moins souvent le tour de france ces
dernières années
alors est ce que c'est une cause à effet
il ya ces c'est possible sur deux
pendant l'été prochain pour faire
envoyer rambouillet paris où tout va
bien c'est vrai dernière étape du tour
de france
mais les c'était plus récurrents c'est
le souvenir c'était quand même plus
récurrents il ya une grosse dizaine
d'années le tour de france la dernière
étape partait plus régulièrement de
compenser c'est peut-être un moyen de
compenser
le fait de pouvoir aller visiter mais
moi ça me va bien je trouve qu'il ya
plein de choses à faire et tant mieux
tant du point raul qu'est ce que vous en
pensez vous tout d'abord la ville des
bréviaires aussi petite soit elle il y
résident 300 habitants et où il réside à
un rat nationale absolument sublime
voilà donc je pense que je pense que
c'est un soin ce n'est pas un choix du
fond de panier ça met en valeur égale ou
et le palais des beaux arts de vienne
n'avait pas d'autres départements mais
j'estime que le département du 78 et
celui qui a peut-être le plus de cacher
dans les yvelines et le plus de de
patrimoine ainsi nommé conseiller de
france par dont edith lefranc et en plus
qui offre un dénivelé qui fait que je
pense que pour un début de course auront
quand même vite dans le vif du sujet et
dans le sublime du sport donc je crois
que on peut encore aller puiser dans les
yvelines sont dans des réserves qui sont
encore riche donc c'est un bon choix
pierre il doit rester pas mal de grandes
villes en fait pour les mêmes même si
c'était à refaire dans une grande ville
pour les premières étapes et canton
quant au village au joli village
d'yveline 2500 habitants et moins pour
accueillir la deuxième est le départ de
la deuxième service étaient 400
habitants pas de problème il y en a
encore parlé dernière d'âge absolument
magnifique par les tours de par vue d
évident non plus vous parlez tous
repartent et est donc maintenant il ya
compensation il faut que paris nice
continue de partir de des civils ça me
va bien
justement j'aimerais qu'on se concentre
un petit peu sur les bréviaires le
bréviaire qu'est ce que vous en pensez
vous jean ah c'est très très bien les
bruits les 300 habitants c'est aussi un
moyen aussi de magnifiques
alors toujours fier d'emmener des
coureurs cyclistes de haut niveau peut
être les meilleurs du monde d emmener au
bréviaire c'est aussi un symbole comme
quoi le cyclisme finalement je pense que
sans les femmes et ça va partout je
pense que ça va les faire rêver comme
dans les landes il vous partez des
bréviaires alors là pas les cyclistes
des habitants ça va les emmener cycliste
moi je parlais non mais on est mal je ne
connaissais pas le nom de ce train
d'arriver je ne connaissais pas les
faire de l'équitation de l'équitation et
je crois je vais attaquer parce qu'il
n'a pas encore assez nourri d'un cheval
qui accueillit il y résident des étalons
problème alors parfait le rendez vous
est pris en tout cas je trouve que c'est
très dur pour les nouveaux ces petits
villages
c'est vraiment très très bien pour ce
petit village on l'a vu l'an dernier
l'engouement qu'on a pu avoir avec orson
ville c'était c'était magique quoi et on
a vu on a vu sur l'interview du maire
kiki et j'irai pas ému mais mécanique
quasiment pour lui ça va être
l'événement de ces quatre dernières
années de ses trois mandats c'est ce qui
me vaut lui d'accord mais même si
j'étais pâmé ravard il était peut-être
du village depuis toujours quoi qu'il
arrive aux personnages
alors les y vivent devrait continuer à
cueillir le paris nice au moins jusqu'en
2021 et peut-être jusqu'en 2024
si les dernières rumeurs se confirment
c'était une bonne nouvelle du couple
sarkozy d'être bien sûr c'est une bonne
nouvelle
il faut préparer les jeux olympiques
également et il faut qu'on prépare les
jeux olympiques il faut qu'on mais qu'on
les prépare bien c'est vrai que paris
nice pourrait servir par exemple de
tests sur sur le
le parcours qui pourrait servir aux jeux
olympiques et ça ce serait une bonne une
bonne idée et ça permet vrai ça fait un
train d'avoir d'avoir des informations
et ça ferait venir beaucoup de monde en
termes de coureurs faut pas oublier que
c'est quand même la première est
première épreuve la première épreuve par
étapes en europe qui ça ouvre la s'ouvre
la saison et c'est vrai que ça reste une
très belle et à une très belle épreuve
avec des très beaux noms qui l'ont
emporté
alors je vous propose maintenant de
parler de handball le club de montigny
le bretonneux enregistré une arrivée de
taille dans ce mercato la joueuse aux
slovènes hanina bleach est chaud vient
de signer dans ce club qui évolue dans
la poule 3 de nationale 2 la joueuse de
34 ans est notamment passé par le club
professionnel de nîmes entre 2011 et
2016 où elle a été élu meilleur arrière
gauche du championnat de france en 2014
elle est est également international
slovène on écoute la réaction du
président du club christophe reining sur
ce plateau
nina en fait à porte à porte beaucoup
sur sur le groupe comme l'a pu le dire
denis non pas que en fait ça va vite ça
joue bien c'est plus que ça c'est à dire
c'est la gossip la culture du
championnat de compétition de haut
niveau et en fait elle à cette notion
motrices en fait d'apporter à tous en
fait ces notions là avec cette arrivée
le club de monty l'aube retenues espère
terminer dans le top 5 de sa poule à la
fin de la saison le club est
actuellement à la 7e place après neuf
journées disputées on voit le classement
voilà sept points 24 points pour
colombienne alors la question sur ce
thème avec nina ricci monti le
bretonneux peut-il à prétendre au podium
en fin de saison
podium podium on va chanter parce que
yann barthes à rimbaud yeux
jimmy sme et vous êtes partager un petit
duel entre l'élève et pierre encore
élève alors je veux pas savoir si je
veux pas être défaitiste ni rien c'est
juste qu'en effet il ya quand même
beaucoup de personnes beaucoup de clubs
déjà avec des meilleurs résultats il ya
beaucoup enfin les résultats sont très
serrés
il ya quand même un gros écart entre 17
et 21 c'est quand même un écart
important
après je sais pas combien de matches et
restent là
on n'est même pas encore à la moitié du
championnat il ya eu au moins ça peut
remonter après il faudrait vraiment
beaucoup travaillé faudrait je sais pas
si elles arriveront jusque jusqu'au
podium après elles peuvent quand même
mal à avoir de bons résultats et bien
monté mais jusqu'au podium aux attentes
si je peux baisser mais je suis pas sûr
pierre une hirondelle peut faire le
printemps une ancienne internationale
qui vient fait compris pour bien faire
le garder pour le best-of de france
vient prendre sa retraite on parlait du
bon vivre dans les yvelines voilà une
retraite internationale avec toute son
expérience qu'elle va apporter dans le
dans la gestion du groupe de ses filles
il reste suffisamment de temps pile dans
le ventre mou il ya un peu d'écart par
rapport au dernier au dernier avant
dernière il y à aussi de l'écart c'est
vrai par rapport au troisième il ya que
4 points
ça peut ça peut créer un effet
psychologique et une vraie une vraie
ambiance rassurante par son expérience
internationale
donc oui j'ai envie de leur souhaiter
avec le plus grand optimisme d'aller
d'au moins de remonter au classement et
pourquoi pas d'aller d'aller titiller le
podium - raul qui vous a convaincu ben
moi j'ai mon propos restent partagés
dans le sens où effectivement l'arrivée
d'une star donne une équipe n'est jamais
négatif parce que forcément il augmente
le niveau on profite de l'expérience de
ce joueur et surtout ça donne une
certaine confiance de sentir épaulés par
des gens d'un certain niveau maintenant
première première chose il faut que la
greffe prenne
alors après effectivement hand ball on
est on est moins nombreux d'entre de
l'apport premier match première victoire
intrants des savanes quart d'heure du
coup attention on fait quoi entre les
halls idolâtre on idolâtre
mais on met sur le devant de la scène un
joueur en oubliant les autres et en se
reposant sur cette espèce de de
surpuissance qu'incarne ce jour là et
c'est là que ça devient très dangereux
c'est pour ça que dans d'autres sports
comme le foot le psg peine toujours à
gagner le championnat parce que eh ben
il invite des stars et puis du coup ça
devient des équipes assez individuel là
c'est la même chose faut faire attention
à ne pas oublier le reste du groupe et
que tout ne soit pas tourner autour de
cette chose là et je crois que ça peut
jouer souvent des tours ce genre de
chose mais bon ça reste je pense quelque
chose de plus positif que négatif
c'est pour ça que je suis voilà
peut-être partager plus plus ce genre
ils ont gagné comme tout qui sont les
dix contre lisieux
on irait de l'avant dernier parle avec
vous quand ils se sont affrontés
l'équipe était avant dernier du
classement et alleo qu'aujourd'hui
dernier éducation d'accord bible cette
équipe donc de 36 à 24 quand même oui
donc tout à fait mais on s'est quand
même
le bas du tableau elles ont joué le bas
du tableau n'est pas tout à fait moi
j'étais j'étais un petit peu mitigé un
petit peu comme raul parce que justement
il l'a dit lui même j'ai pas révéler ce
qu'il a dit et cette joueuse amènera
certainement plus c'est sûr mais après
c'est quand même un collectif même s'il
ya pas beaucoup de moyens beaucoup moins
de joueurs au handball qui peut y avoir
au rugby ou au football mais elle
amènera quelque chose certes mais c'est
pas non plus elle qui va faire tout le
jeu d'un collectif
donc c'est un plus pour l'équipe
maintenant de là à dire ça y est
maintenant en as tu joué sept joueuses
et on va écraser tout le monde je moi je
n'y crois pas je leur souhaite mais je
n'y crois pas parce que c'est y avoir
plus collectif qu'à rien que ça et c'est
le sport très collectif c'est physique
et collectif
ça c'est proche du rugby c'est très
physique et collectif donc une joueuse
peut faire la différence
certes mais de là à transformer l'équipe
à règle générale je n'y crois pas pas ce
niveau pas pas autant papa autres yann
il aurait peut-être fallu la signer
avant au début la saison
oui peut-être fallu la signer avant oui
c'est une possibilité maintenance et
c'est une opportunité encore une fois
c'est encore un coup de bol elle arrive
elle arrive ici pour raisons
personnelles et donc du coup elle va
jouer dans le club dont club local le
plus le plus capé donc tant mieux pour
eux moi ce que je vois c'est quand même
depuis le début depuis le début de la
saison ses troisièmes à maputo
versailles en a un au basket à enchaîner
et puis un ancien déjà chaque fois des
anciens internationaux des anciens
grands noms donc donc c'est cool pour
les pour les clubs il ya dans les villes
on est bien dans les élites voilà ça
veut dire qu'il fait beau vivre ici non
plus tôt dans la saison
voilà c'est parce que la seule chose que
je vois en positif c'est que là les
filles elles n'ont qu'une chose à faire
c'est de se dire maintenant on peut
regarder le haut du tableau
c'est à dire que là on était au mieux le
tableau il fallait pas à descendre parce
qu'il y avait un gros écart par rapport
par rapport à l'avant là on sait que on
a un gros renfort et on va pouvoir aller
grappiller gratter des gratter des
places et est peut-être maintenant ça
doit pas dépendre que d'elle elle va
falloir qu'elle joue et que la
mayonnaise prenne
et si jamais ça prend à falloir aussi
aller se servir des défaites adverse
pour pouvoir remonter donc là elles ont
une opportunité et c'est peut-être ça
pour moi en tant que sportive sid un
sport co si j'avais une arrivée comme ça
je me dirais là il faut que moi aussi je
fasse le nécessaire pour pouvoir élever
mon niveau et lui servir et que ça
servira au groupe donc là c'est vraiment
un
c'est un discours du coach c'est un
discours de 2,2 tout le monde et c'est
là-dessus qu'il faut jouer et tout le
monde doit jouer le coup à fond en
espérant même mais par contre il faut
aussi espérer que l art est un peu plus
longtemps parce que si elle est là juste
six mois doit résister au minimum un an
et demi d'accord il est donc
donc là il ya vraiment quelque chose à
construire sur sur un moyen terme
pas de court terme est quand même voilà
un petit peu plus qu'avant d'accord mais
bon voilà il ya déjà quelque chose à
jouer et a créé pour pour pour
pour la fin de saison et pour la saison
prochaine il y ait d une grosse
opportunité et il faut il faut y aller a
en tout cas elle devrait apporter du
leadership ni naïri cheech s'est blessé
à la main lors de son premier match elle
s'est même cassé un os mais elle a quand
même voulu continuer à écouter sa
réaction c'est vrai que j'ai eu mal mais
comme comme je voulais juste gagner le
match voilà donc j'ai continué je me
suis dit ok je suis pas bon en précision
donc je vais dire à mes coéquipières je
vais plus distribuer les jouets et voilà
comme ça je joue et roumains tchèques
jan ça vous est déjà arrivé d'avoir un
joueur qui dissimulait une blessure pour
terminer le match
beaucoup trop non aux fouilles des
dangers que fait ceci laisse s'est cassé
la main en fait ouais ben ça a changé
effet bon personnel je venais cassez ont
donc plusieurs fois mais oui ça dépend
des joueurs parce que c'est léger c'est
une génération une génération où il joue
plus il joue plus blessé qu'un les
joueurs là c'est fini ils sonnaient tous
élevés du coton donc d'exiger un petit
bobo il arrête mais c'est vrai que j'ai
connu une génération ou même blessé mais
avec des doigts cassés ou de nez cassé
ou ça continue à jouer oui si on emballe
quand même
on s'en sert de la main alors je sais
pas si c'est la même si ce sens si c'est
ça c'est ça mais non plus donc ouais
c'est courageux c'est très courageux et
singulière oui elles sont vides 1 m 72
ha bon elle a l'air beaucoup plus grande
et solide e par mètre 72
elle est physique elle et tous les
passants fois désolé mais c'est parce
que vous trouvez sur les élèves beaucoup
plus grande et elisabeth est très
athlétique
c'est très courageux de finir le match
va se faire opérer pour revenir dans
quatre semaines
sinon son cette opération là elle ne
revenait pas de la saison c'est xavier
qui voilà que cette fois été spectateur
mais qui vient régulièrement sur ce
plateau
hélène qu'est ce que ça vous inspire
brook qu'elle joue avec une main cassée
ça montre que déjà elle vient d'un
environnement quand même pas au niveau
où elle est celle ci s exigent des
résultats sains a porté son équipe elle
a vraiment l'esprit d'équipé on parlait
surtout tout à l'heure du fait qu'elle
va peut-être pas forcément rester très
très longtemps
je pense que en effet il faut pas se
reposer sur elle uniquement sur elle
il faut vraiment prendre tout ce qui est
à apprendre et se servir tout ça pour
faire grandir tous les membres de
l'équipe pour qu'après puisse être
autonome sans elle est lassée elle donne
une leçon en continuant à jouer
voilà donc on espère qu'elle va se
rétablir et que pour apporter comme ça
les membres de l'équipe plus vert plus
haut et plus de capacité et puis c'est
un petit peu l'héroïne ils modèlent quoi
donc il faut suivre en tout cas ça ne
l'a pas empêché de marquer trois buts en
quatre tirs en quand même sur cette
partie avec une main cassée alors on va
passer maintenant notre page coup de
projecteur
dans ce coup de projecteur je vous
propose un tour d'horizon des événements
sportifs qui vont marquer l'année 2019
dans les yvelines après une année
exceptionnelle marquée par
l'organisation de la ryder cup à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines 2019 devrait
également être un très bon cru
regardez 2019 sera placée sous le signe
du sport dans les yvelines l'année
débutera par un combat de boxe le ces
souris prochain et en courtois marvin
petit va tenter de remporter un titre
européen dans la catégorie des poids
légers face aux belges francesco pas
terreur aux mahorais que j'attends
depuis depuis pas déjà regarde depuis
toujours
quoi que je n'aurais jamais urgent que
jamais cru entendre roy dans ce combat
oui là qui me disent favori il puis
l'ena qui me disent que ça va être un
combat difficile dure
après moi je sais que l'art est un
combat tu vas être physique physique
puis physiquement je serai là j'ai
toujours une physique ginfray rien et je
pense que je vais lui faire très très
mal
2019 par craint également le retour du
jumping de versailles après avoir annulé
l'édition 2018 faute de date disponible
les organisateurs ont programmé ce
concours hippique de sauts d'obstacles
international du 26 au 28 avril en face
du château
autre retour après 20 ans d'absence les
championnats de france féminin par
équipes nationales pas de gymnastique
reviennent en ile de france
la compétition sera organisée au
vélodrome national de saint quentin en
yvelines
on attend mille quatre cents gymnastes
sur les trois jours qui seront qui font
la compétition et on espère atteindre
cent mille personnes
sur ces événements aux spectateurs à
quelques mètres du vélodrome nationale
l'île de loisirs de saint quentin en
yvelines accueillera le samedi 16 mars
l'eco trail de paris des milliers de
coureurs vont s'élancer depuis train
pour parcourir 80 km jusqu'à la tour
eiffel
on part sur la base de loisirs de saint
quentin et puis on part dans un une
espèce de chant qui est relativement
beau ce n'est pas évident pour les
filles donc faut faire faut rester
attentif aux trouver le bon rythme parce
ce cra metroid en golf l'open de france
aura une nouvelle fois organisé sur le
golf national de saint quentin en
yvelines
cette année le rendez vous ne sera pas
programmé fin juin mais du 17 au 20
octobre et devient l'avant dernier
tournoi de la saison en europe
l'open de france en juin a pu souffrir
par le passé d'une trop grande proximité
de tat avec roland garros où avec le
tour de france ou avec le rôle mondial
de foot
donc on pense qu'en étant remplacé en
deuxième partie de saison là on a un
coup à jouer si on peut dire
il y aura enfin du cyclisme de haut
niveau sur le territoire pour la dixième
année consécutive le paris-nice et
lancera des yvelines le 10 mars
le parcours sera officiellement dévoilé
ce mercredi 9 janvier toujours sur la
route aux rambouillet sera ville départ
sur la 26e et dernière étape du tour de
france le dimanche 26 juillet plus de
40000 spectateurs sont attendus pour
l'événement enfin le stadium de bmx de
saint quentin en yvelines on recevra
deux manches du circuit de coupe du
monde et de coupe de france les 8 et 10
juin prochains
le calendrier 2010 9 et fixer les
yvelinois le demandent maintenant à qu'à
vibrer la question sur ce thème quel est
l'évènement que vous attendez le plus
en 2019 vous dire oralement la ville
j'adore ce sport jeu là c'est vraiment
puisque la course jusqu'à course en
ligne mais un petit peu moins que la
piste mais ya rien pour la piste cette
année
meiway dans le bmx trouve ça super
spectaculaire c'est quelque chose qui
est accessible à tout le monde
les courses s'enchaînent il y avait un
peu de chutes
il ya un biais du contact c'est qu'ils
voir ces mecs-là avancer sans pédaler
moi je sais pas comment ils font
générerait et donc voilà pour moi c'est
c'est ça c'est le bmx et en plus c'est
l'événement c'est mon tour du monde
deux manches de coupe du monde voilà les
dernières de coupe de france
et en terme de prestige c'est
l'événement qui sera le plus le plus
high level voilà l'année dernière c'est
la ryder cup parce que ben ali a pas
mieux
il ya des coureurs du monde entier ont
ils des néo zélandais des amis avec un c
c'est pour ça donc là c'est pour moi
c'est ça qui est ça qui pour le gaz de
ville on va dire on va dire l'open
l'open de france d'abord l'open de
france en espérant qu'ils puissent
changer de date dans l'est dans les
années qui suivent
mais où à dire la retransmission de la
coupe du monde de rugby qui m'ont
craintes ne manquera pas d'être d'être
justement retransmis dans les yvelines
si je commence mal la résolution de
l'année hall troubler le retour de mon
partenaire marvin sur sur le ring enfin
le retour de mes chevaux chez le roi
soleil
enfin aussi des jolies femmes en
gymnastique donc et puis aussi le ça va
être aussi l'événement test parce que
l'open de france il a aussi connu avec
la perte de son sponsor un coup dur
on attend aussi l'événement on attend un
peu de voir les retombées de cet
événement qui perd un petit peu en grade
donc ces riches moi je suis j'attends
tout ça avec énormément d'impatience
justement le jumping de versailles qui
revient alors qu'ils n'avaient pas
trouvé une date l'année dernière c'est
vraiment peut-être la meilleure nouvelle
finalement sur
bien sûr sur de ces grands événements
qui ont marqué l'année d un studio et
puis ça reste encore disons que on est
on est toujours en train de se poser la
question de savoir si les épreuves
olympiques auront lieu là-bas donc tous
les événements qui ont lieu dans ce dans
ce complexe la permettront de se décider
pour ma part mes positions sont fermes
j'espère qu'elles auront lieu dans le
château de versailles donc ça permettra
de vraiment se prendre confiance en la
conception de désapprouver casse dans là
bas vous allez y être et j'espère y
participer surtout pour le faire
explique cela genre personnellement ce
sera le combat de marine petit vous êtes
plus boxe oui oui oui je vous a senti
plutôt passionnée par paris nice
également mais après pour au niveau de
l'engouement et du nombre de deux des
personnes que ça peut ça peut ça peut
concerner le paris-nice et puis l'étape
du tour de france sacré quand même un
bel engouement dans nos départements
donc c'est que ce sont de belles
manifestations sportives bon moi le
cyclisme je regarde et pourquoi marvin
petit du coup le combat de boxe parce
que je pense que j'ai déjà j'aime bien
ce boxeur j'aime bien j'aime bien ça son
parcours
et puis voilà il va il va combattre pour
un titre européen
il valait encore essayer d'aller
chercher plus haut donc voilà ça ça me
plaît c'est l'état d'esprit qui me plaît
pour ce 2019
hélène bon parce que je trouve qu'on
parle pas c'est parce que raul aura la
place de de faire la groupie non mais
j'aime j'aime l'endroit et j'aime le
fait que justement on en parle et que ce
soit un vrai événement en plus qu'on
n'ait pas pu le comment dire de
programmes et l'an dernier voilà il est
temps que ce soit reprogrammé et bmx
vraiment pour le kotéba comme tu disais
spectaculaire c'est un spectacle donc
voilà en plus voilà du côté du côté
sport c'est aussi un spectacle les deux
d'ailleurs mais voilà les dents même
temps les championnats de france en tout
cas de gymnastique ça sera vraiment la
grosse nouveauté de cette année
pierre chevalier grosse nouveauté c'est
la première fois depuis vingt ans qu'une
compétition d'une telle ampleur revient
en ile-de-france et dans un vélo et dans
un vélo donc ça c'est assez normal et
l'attractivité des lieux événementiels
des civils et sur une discipline qui est
et reste populaire malgré tout parce que
le les jeunes filles et les jeunes
garçons pratiquent pratique déjà à
l'école ça c'est un sport qui est de
fait populariser ce sport très exigeant
beaucoup de préparation spectaculaire
parce que beaucoup d'agrément au coup de
beaucoup de discipline donc une vraie
une vraie occasion de hbo sports et de
spectacles dans les yvelines encore une
fois vous êtes d'accord
oui ça c'est prête le vélodrome pour une
conversion comme celle là si on a on a
quand même un a quand même contre x
quand on est là on a une vraie
visibilité sur le sur le parc le parc
central
même si la piste fait perdre un petit
peu de un petit peu prendre un proxy ce
temps sa proximité voilà
mais c'est vrai que le nom your house ça
si près de complètement bon ça veut dire
que le vélodrome ne veut pas encore
accessible semaine pour nous c'est une
bonne galère et après oui c'est vrai que
je pense que tout le monde ici a vu la
vidéo delà de la date américaine qui a
fait un avis un bon buzz avec a fait un
très très gros buzz ces derniers jours
c'est ouais sédhiou si elle est quand on
arrive à ce niveau concerne justement
cette opération non les fanas du monde
encore soit un peu plus dans l axe nati
cause à gré elle se suffit à elle-même
on en parle lorsque lé giro les jeunes
filles ont envie de pratiquer ce sport
parce qu'on ne découvre simplement à
l'école on en fait tous au collège tu as
raison tu a raison de le dire
donc ça suffit pour pouvoir pour pouvoir
se développer il se suffit pour pouvoir
se développer maintenant un gros
événement comme ça sur sur les yvelines
mais tant mieux pour les pratiquantes
des yvelines parce que ben vous pouvoir
aller voir un bel événement et un haut
niveau et de toute façon c'est toujours
agréable d'aller voir des beaux des
beaux matchs des beaux combats des
belles démonstrations canton quand on
est le sport donc donc c'est super genre
qu'est ce que vous en pensez vous de ces
championnats de france de gymnastique et
fais-moi café des années le cheval
d'arçons
c'est très bien c'est très bien ah oui
c'est magnifique c'est magnifique
non mais c'est bien il faut il faut me
dis qu'il faut ça il faut ce genre de
compétition pour que le vélodrome puisse
vivre un peu parce que sinon on attend
des compétitions de cyclisme
en programmant nouvelle rom donc mais
c'est une réalité et se dire quand on
propose du vélo au vélodrome il ya
personne ne l'a tous les sports vous
arrivez à convaincre oeil alors il y
aura du monde - pour cette même
compétition de neymar a couru un grand
prix un week-end dernier il y avait des
traces on avait fait un bon tour à jo
l'année dernière c'est un vrai jeu court
pas pour voir du monde
très rapidement l'open de france de golf
qui sera au mois d'octobre
c'est un rendez vous que vous attendez
pierre chevalier oui atteint sans fin
d'inconditionnels j'avais vingt secondes
j'ai vingt secondes cc oui ça
rendez-vous inconditionnel il a été
déclassé il a été décalé au mois
d'octobre
ça reste une compétition théoriquement
on espère avec un beau plateau
il est question que le la date change en
2020 et son avancée en septembre
c'est tout ce qu'on peut souhaiter à ce
bel événement maintenant sur ce beau
parcours du golf national qui marque
mondialement connue voter une seconde
on va terminer par une citation du
basketteur michael jordan j'ai manqué
plus de 9000 tiers dans ma carrière j'ai
perdu plus de 300 parties à 26 reprises
on m'a fait confiance pour le tir
gagnant et je les manquer j'ai subi de
nombreux échecs dans ma vie c'est pour
cela que j'ai réussi je vous laisse
méditer sur cette phrase à bientôt sur
tv 78
[Musique]